if we've talked about this briefly but
like different in a different scenario
if someone called you from the
arrowverse which they call it now of
course I've always called it but if
someone called you and said hey we want
you to do a guest star come back as the
arrow for one of these shows just an
episode or two sure be honest would you
be like that's not what I want to do or
would you consider it oh it all depend
the storyline
this the storyline the money the less so
the money because you're not
you're not the star anymore of the show
well but also this is a this is this is
a one-off
right it would be you're going back for
for an episode or two episodes you're
not going back to recreate the show
right so you know the money
everyone's gonna haggle but you're not
gonna get an extra four million dollars
out of them you might no you might you
might get your quote or half your quote
or something sure but it it would more
it would more come down to
you know I like
I like going online and I like seeing
reaction videos right when fans see
something in a television show that they
like so I would think to myself as a fan
of whatever show
how pumped would I be if so-and-so
character just appeared so from that
from that angle I'd probably be like
yeah let's do it but again depends on
the depends on the show it really like I
know that this sounds like
keep in mind that I'm honest because I
said earlier that I got into acting
originally to be famous so so believe me
when I say that this really would come
down to the storyline sure
but I think that if anyone's listening
like uh what's his name creator of uh
Arrow Greg Valencia Greg Valencia wanted
to forget his name he put his name and
TV
if if he was listening or other
producers were listening and they go oh
it's not about the money we can get him
for a price let's just get a good
[ __ ] story I think he just messed up
Steve no I don't no no no no
I know how it I I know how I know how it
works I I know how it works because I
because I you know I've I've been on the
other side of helping someone with this
negotiation so I know precisely how it
goes all right there would never be a
conversation about money it would be a
conversation about story yeah